we begin with breaking developments as
it relates to the scandal of front and
Biden's White House it's bad now tonight
two top officials Secretary of State
Tony winken blinken and attorney general
politicized the justice department
Garland have been credibly accused of
serious misconduct and it all revolves
around who else Hunter Biden all right
now breaking tonight we're learning that
your secretary of state is Shady he's
lying he's a hack he's not to be trusted
now remember remember that bogus October
2020 letter 51 former Intel experts all
claiming that the hunter Biden laptop
had quote all of the classic earmarks of
a Russian information operation they all
said this with no knowledge at all
whatsoever because none of them saw the
laptop now this is the very letter that
big Tech and the media mob used to
discredit and censor the very true
Hunter Biden laptop story only days
before the 2020 presidential election
all right so our friend an investigative
reporter editor-in-chief at just
thenews.com John Solomon is now
reporting that a former CIA director
Mike Morrell admitted to Congress that
he organized that letter in for the
reason to influence the 2020 election
now he did it at the direction of Tony
winken blinken now at the time Lincoln
was working as a foreign affairs advisor
for the Biden campaign they organized
this of course we know that the FBI was
meeting weekly with big Tech remember
they were warning them that they might
be victims of a disinformation campaign
and according to the former Twitter site
Integrity head a guy by the name of Joel
Roth at at the time he said the FBI
specifically warned that it might be
about Joe or Hunter Biden now the FBI
had Hunter Biden's laptop since December
of 2019 they could have easily
authenticated that or maybe they even
did but the FBI also knew that President
Trump's attorney at the time that would
be Rudy Giuliani had a copy and that
information would likely leak you see
how this all now comes together now so
when the New York Post first reported
the details of that laptop from Hell
while Tony blinken was ready with a plan
to deceive you the American people as
Biden was entering or trying to get that
office and win the election Lincoln was
richly rewarded by the Biden White House
when he won with the most coveted
cabinet position Secretary of State all
because he organized one of the most
egregious disinformation lying campaigns
in American history he in this case he's
got to be held accountable there is no
doubt that Tony blinken helped to propel
Joe Biden who doesn't know that tonight
is Thursday to the White House
and also kept the Biden family Syndicate
in business but he's not the only Biden
official who was caught lying this week
in service to Joe and Hunter the
Attorney General Merrick Garland is now
reportedly accused of lying under oath
about the uh federal investigation into
Hunter Biden's finances now last night
we learned that an IRS criminal case
supervisor has filed for official
whistleblower protection now the
supervisor claims to have evidence that
contradicts the sworn testimony of quote
a senior political appointee we believe
that person is the A.G Mary Garland
according to the Whistleblower Hunter is
receiving preferential treatment in
other words Hunter's criminal case is
being mishandled swept under the rug
apparently and keep in mind the
Whistleblower is not a political person
he or she gains nothing from coming
forward except probably abuse on fake
news CNN and msdnc but is still choosing
to do the right thing say now here's the
whistleblower's attorney earlier today
on with Brett Baer take a look my client
wants to come forward he's not a
political person he's not a social media
person he's not coming here with a
political agenda he's been at the IRS
for a long time he's been at the IRS for
more than 10 years uh as and now he's a
supervisory special agent he's been
trusted at the IRS he's uh he's actually
been trusted as an assistant special
agent in charge in other cities
entrusted with International
investigations and working with other
countries tax enforcement uh bureaus now
this IRS supervisor is doing the right
thing though through the appropriate
channels but now Hunter Biden's attorney
is now threatening this whistleblower
accusing him of committing a crime
simply for coming forward to expose what
he believes to be misconduct take a look
my client wrestled with whether or not
to come forward he had a lot of
sleepless nights about coming forward
with this at the end of the day he
decided that he could not live with
himself if he stayed quiet and said
nothing so he's coming forward but he
knows that he's going to be attacked and
you know really attacks like this are
kind of what he was worried about but he
wants to come forward tell the truth you
see that as fairly threatening that that
you know I don't think it helps uh you
know I don't think it helps
whistleblowers as a whole I mean uh
there there is a strong contention on
the hill that believes in The
Whistleblower programs to have to shine
a light on government agencies and
programs and to enable people to come
forward without getting threatened and
it's unfortunate that that statement was
made all right but wait a minute I think
back don't Democrats Revere
whistleblowers
that's right I think they do remember
during Trump they even like hearsay
whistleblowers anyway they were praised
they were exalted and yet fake new CNN
MSD and see they care they're going to
ignore the story this major story why is
that the answer is simple they don't
really care about whistleblowers only
ones that are against Donald Trump and
they want to protect Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden and you better believe that
the current federal investigation into
Hunter Biden and the Biden Syndicate in
the whole family is likely going to
implicate the big guy big time and his
10 or taking half his salary as Hunter
whined in his own laptop hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else